one of the biggest differences between
humanity and animals is that we are
toolmakers
for every job we do for every task we
have we design we build we optimize a
specific tool whether that's a
screwdriver for screwing the screws an
automatic defibrillator for bringing
dead people back to life
or any of the range of blades we used
for everything from sushi through to
navigating the jungle we make a tool for
it and yet I'm willing to bet that the
most popular tool in the room right now
is one of these
it's a multi-tool it's not particularly
optimized for anything it's not
especially the best in class but it's
one convenient package that fits right
in your pocket and has enough of
everything that you need that this is
the tool that you carry around it is the
most powerful tool and you finally do
the same thing with software the
software we build and use looks a lot
like a set of individual tools highly
optimized for a specific purpose
searching files modifying files
compressed and decompressing encrypting
decrypting uploading downloading and yet
the tool that we pick up most often the
tool that we love the most
tends to be a tool more like Python that
does all of these things it's not
optimized to any particular one but it
has everything in one convenient package
it is the multi-tool and that's great
for us it's terrible for security most
of our security systems
work on the level of tools tools of
their atomic element because they're
mostly runners processes and we can
handle those we can see when they start
we can see when they stop we can prevent
them from starting we can force them to
stop and we can see what they were told
to do but when you have a multi-tool
like Python you can't necessarily see
inside of that living off the land is a
phrase that you hear in information
security quite often it refers to this
idea that when an attacker gets into
your machine they can't always bring
their own tools with them and so they're
going to use what's already there
anything that you've deployed onto your
machines or that as part of the
operating system is available for their
use because you need it
and so if you're using a tool to
download files off the internet then
they can also use that the way to avoid
this is to simply not deploy them don't
leave your tools laying around if
they're not needed this is about
minimizing a tack surface this means
that when someone gets into your machine
they can only do a very limited set of
things and you control what that is and
you're aware of what that is which
raises the question is Python necessary
in your production system it is the most
powerful tool if it's there what if it's
used for an attack what if you say yes
now python is essential must be deployed
because we're using it and then you get
hacked
and you find out because your customer
database shows up on the internet and
the review goes through and finds out
that the attackers used python that was
already on your machine and got it out
and you had no idea why would you
distracting processes pythons started
that's the idea that's why we put it
there we want to use it you're looking
at network connections and there's
nothing suspicious they got in through a
developer machine they access it all the
time why would you notice it when
abnormal use looks normal
your only choice is to watch everything
we said again when you're when abnormal
use looks like normal use you have to
watch everything you have to track
everything that happens on your
production machine you have to track
everything on any machine connected to
it any machine connected to that and put
it all in one place and you build this
massive massive haystack and you're
gonna go search for a needle and if that
sounds impossible you're right it is so
we take a slightly different approach
let me reframe how a lot of us will
think about security it's very easy idea
imagine you have your high value
whatever it is high value of machines
high value database high value software
and you build a wall around it that
keeps the attackers out and that's
largely how we think about software
security network security is we have a
wall to defend and infinite akha gets
through that wall if they breach that
wall then they win and we lose
and now the problem with this point of
view is that you can't defend that
entire wall that wall is millions and
millions and millions of individual
points where an attacker can get through
and they only have to get lucky once and
they will so the mindset that we try and
switch to in more modern information
security is known as assumed breach we
assume that they're going to get in and
for the most part this is a good
assumption they already have if you have
an interesting system at all there's
probably some kind of attack already
going on inside that you don't know
about yet by making this assumption we
design things differently we build
systems differently because we're not
just trying to detect a breach at the
wall we want to detect any motion going
on inside the system that doesn't look
normal and so you build a bigger and
bigger haystack of everything but you're
not just looking for the initial
intrusion anymore you're looking for any
use of your software that doesn't look
like your application you're essentially
putting motion detectors inside your
office even though the front door is
closed and this is why python is
dangerous because those motion detectors
are looking at tools and python is a
multi-tool that can do everything so
when you see Python being used you don't
actually know what it's done it's kind
of like if someone borrows your
screwdriver goes away for an hour and
then comes back you've got a pretty good
idea where they've done with it they buy
the Titan something Oh loosen something
if someone borrows your multi-tool comes
back an hour later what have they done
you have no idea maybe they've cut
something maybe they've what can you do
with this eaten something maybe they've
trim their toenails in Starbucks with it
you don't know what they've been up to
and python is just like that here's an
example command that you might see
logged in a very broad security system
this is one tool we're starting a
process here but you can see everything
that's doing we know that Cole downloads
stuff we know that's a URL we can kind
of see what's there and we know where
it's being put and we can make a
decision about whether this is
good or bad what is this one doing this
is a legitimate Python invocation this
command will do something I know what it
does it will go to the internet and it
will download more code and it will
decrypt that code and execute that code
and it's not actually going to start
uploading stuff because I worried that
people will take this and actually run
it so it just prints a hello a message
but looking at the logs you couldn't
know what this does you can't make a
value judgment based on what this does
because you don't know what it does this
is a totally likely command that you may
see this is lateral traversal this is a
machine picking up a program arbitrary
code on another machine within your
network so there's no random network
connections here you may not see this
but it is running arbitrary code on your
machine and maybe this is how they get
in in the first place because most tools
are not going to squiggle a misspelled
package name for you but this is
downloading arbitrary code off the
internet and running it inside Python
and you don't know what it did this is
why Python is dangerous this is why you
should not put piped-in on your systems
but pythons essential Python is what all
of your code is running on it's what
your algorithms are written in it's the
flexibility that's gotten you to market
so quickly it's the maintainability that
lets you make changes reliably and trust
that they're going to be ok
it's the reason you can hire so easily
from one of the biggest and fastest
growing tools of talent in the world
right now python is quarter your
business could score do success and so
you can't just disable it the signaling
Python is not an option
but it doesn't have to be despite the
security concerns imagine imagine we
have the same setup where we're
collecting all of these events we're
collecting all of the tools that start
but instead of being a black box like
python is instead of having a secret
life that you know nothing about imagine
it was telling you imagine if every
- built into Python built into that
multi-tool was individually telling you
what it was doing as it was doing it and
giving you that ability to treat the
multi-tool as a box of independent tools
instead imagine Python was your early
warning system an attacker using Python
is going to be doing things with it that
you don't normally do so when they come
in and they run you'll see in the logs
of Python started great
it was started thousands of times you
don't even notice but if we can see the
individual things that's doing if we can
see the remote hosts it's connecting to
the files it's accessing the commands
it's running that's gonna trigger red
flags because those don't look a thing
like our application how could you miss
it
you may not necessarily act on that but
you know about it assume breach means
you don't lose when the attacker gets in
it means you win whenever you discover
them because then you can respond and
this is where Python 3.8 comes in
because in Python 3.8 we added that way
to get the information out the feature
is called auditing clocks and it's a
fairly low-level feature in Python 3/8
it's intended for the the people who are
managing your system managing your
deployment to be able to say yes we can
deploy Python imagine if every time
c-types is used it would tell you what
commands is being run what modules are
being loaded socket is going to tell you
every IP address it connects to that's
what this provides and it looks like
this we have a hook which is a callback
function the arguments it takes the name
of the event and the arguments very much
like run a command at the command line
it's going to give us that same
information this is the simplest hook I
could possibly write while still using
an F string but yours is more likely
going to send that event somewhere else
so that you can collect it centrally
with everything else
adding the hook to enable it goes
through a function the system uh jewel
at audit hook you can only add them you
can't remove them you can add as many as
you like in the loggia code but that's
it
you don't have to do any additional work
at that point you don't have to go
through and enable them there's a whole
lot of points in the standard library
where they're already being enabled but
if you own a third-party module if you
own something that is not cpython
that has low-level operations it's
possible to raise that event as well
Jango for example probably a less
applicable example here than other
places I've given this talk has sequel
generation it will generate sequel code
from its object model and send that to
the database with a single line change
you can expose all of that through an
auditing hook and enable your security
monitoring software to recognize that
that's going on and maybe that's not
going to identify anything bad straight
away but the aim is to identify anything
unusual and that gives you the
additional information and context to
see what's going on now if we're doing
this for security putting it in Python
code is not really ideal because it has
to run as part of the program turns out
when you go to the people who write
malicious software and say hey can you
add an audit hook at the start of it so
I can see everything you're doing they
just say no and so we need a better
solution this may be the first time
we've seen some C code on the screen at
this conference and I do not apologize
for that so C Python is written in C and
you can also add an audit hook in native
code so again it's a callback simplest
possible callback we take the event name
just as a string because it's always
guaranteed to be a string the arguments
is a tuple and we add the hook in much
the same way the important difference
here is this file is in fact the entire
- Dexy implementation or alternatively
the Python entry point on other
platforms and all of the runtime is in a
separate library so you can recompile
this on essentially any system and
replace your Python Dexy with one that
will always add the audit hook no matter
how it started no matter what
configuration is setup it will always be
collecting events and information which
means that no matter how someone gets
onto your system if they start running
Python you will know about it and also
importantly we can add this hook before
Python even starts that pie bytes main
function is where Python starts and by
adding a hook before that we collect
every piece of
information you added in Python code
you'll miss a whole lot of startup we
have one additional hook as well which
is only available in C code it's called
the open code hook most operating
systems have a concept of loading a file
that contains executable data is not the
same thing as opening a file that just
has plain old data and so it has
additional security for like running
binaries and loading executable modules
Python doesn't have that all the files
are just files and the ones that have
code don't normally get treated any
differently what the open code hook let
sister is intercept that when it's a
code file and do additional work in a
very simple case will extract the path
and will open it as we normally would
verify it in some form I have an example
of this later on but that verification
maybe does the content match what I
expect does the hash of the content
match what I expect does it have some
marker does it there's a lot of things
you can do at this point because you
have the contents of the file where as
an ordered hook you don't have the
contents of the file the difference
between noted hook and this as we return
a value we return the file ready to read
well maybe we've read it and transformed
it and returned something different in
memory it's more options this is
primarily to help avoid timing attacks
which would otherwise appear if you are
only looking at the ordered events so
here are the api's we have six api's
sorry two for adding audit hooks two for
sending ordered events and true for
handling the open code and these help
ensure that python no longer keeps any
secrets by integrating python into your
security infrastructure whatever that is
using these hooks you will see
everything that's doing and as necessary
you can influence what it's doing in the
same way as if each tool was
individually controllable so I've been
very abstract let's get to some concrete
examples all of my so I have three
examples for three primary scenarios
that you would care about the first is
enabling known-good code because these
this is a controlled deployment system
you know what code you've put out there
and you only want to enable that
to run this can obviously be bypassed in
certain ways because that's what an
attack is going to try to do and we
assume that they will succeed at some
point so the second scenario is blocking
known bad code in a set in essence a
malware scanner is essentially this
that's what my example will be when I
get to that the third scenario is log
everything that's the most important one
you can try and block you can try and
block things that's a very aggressive
move against your own developers and if
you block things incorrectly you will
lose developers and if you don't block
enough things you will be attacked but
if you log everything you will know that
you've been attacked and that's the
important thing my three examples are
going to be based on the windows
services that you would use when
implementing the Sun windows it's
possible to implement all of these on
other platforms as well so a little bit
more work Windows has the nice factor
that there's one obvious way to do each
one and they're all fairly
straightforward integrations so I'm
gonna go with those examples all right
if you are interested in other platforms
feel free to come chat to me later most
critically if you own another platform
and are responsible for providing Python
on that platform I would love to talk to
you because you're probably the best
person to provide these kind of
connectors for your systems so allowing
trusted code and the service we use for
this on Windows is called Windows
Defender application control the basic
concept is that the operating system
owns the configuration by default
nothing is allowed to run and you have a
big configuration file that says the
things that are allowed to run the OS
manages all of that if you're interested
in how it keeps that secure come and
chat to me afterwards it is fairly
impressive but I'm not gonna go through
it in detail right now the important
thing is the operating system handles
that configuration and it can be queried
for a certain file but it starts by
blocking everything and it blocks
everything in a nice interactive way
where your application is just not
allowed to run by default this works for
executable files or things that the
kernel knows it's executing doesn't work
on plain old Python files and so with
this integration we're going to use the
open code hook to enable the same
configuration to apply to Python sauce
so that if you're on that one of these
can probably configured machines you can
run your code if you've enabled it
through the configuration through the
policy otherwise it will be blocked
configuration is XML this is about 0.1%
of an actual configuration file
they are extensive there are also some
really good tools for automatically
generating it and the general advice is
set up a machine that you know is still
safe and run a scan tool that will look
at everything that you use on it and
generate it for you from that but I want
to give some examples of the kinds of
rules you have file based rules which
are going to allow a deny specific files
based on various metadata either the
file name the full file path if you know
exactly where it will be on the system
the hash of the file you can also use
publisher information version
information to allow and deny certain
programs from being run the more
interesting one is you can also specify
site signing certificates so Windows has
an integrated code signing architecture
where certificates can be marked as
trusted and any code that's been signed
with that certificate will be allowed to
run and this is how we do this here this
certificate is the Python Software
Foundation certificate it's the one used
to sign all the Python releases for
Windows or the official ones and so by
enabling it in here we enable the Python
Software Foundation version of Python
and that includes so dot py files are
not directly sign abour but you can sign
a catalog file that references all of
them and windows knows how to verify
that so we haven't actually done a huge
amount of configuration outside of this
to make it work but the important part
is the integration in the open code hook
this is a helper function that's going
to implement most of the check so the
verify file descriptor we saw earlier
this is that helper function it's going
to take in the file name and an open
handle for that which that and the
parameter extraction was we're not going
to see for this one we stuff it into the
structure that we need for the call but
then we make one call into the operating
system and say what is the policy for
this file the OS is going to look at
that big configure a
file and say this da py file with this
hash is allowed is not allowed whatever
if it comes back and says it's not
allowed we should enforce lockdown
against this file then we'll bail out
and say this file is blocked don't run
it otherwise it's allowed and it's okay
this is the integration this is fairly
straightforward the idea is to put as
much logic centralized because you're
going to be using it for your entire
system this is not so much a Python
logging system as the ability to
integrate Python into the systems you
already have and so a connector should
be fairly straightforward what this
looks like when you run it my first
example is importing the collections
module so this is in the Python standard
library it comes already it comes with a
signed signature in the catalog file and
so it's allowed when I import it now I
modify the random module so it doesn't
match that signature anymore and when I
go to lo it load it it's blocked by
policy which is the fancy way of saying
Windows Defender application control
blocked this it's not allowed on this
machine what this enables is about as
integrated way as as we have to restrict
a machine to only run the things that's
meant to have anything new arrives it
cannot be executed but as I said the
attack is a smart they only have to find
one way through it and when they do that
we want we still want to have a way to
stop them deploying the configuration is
a big task and so when we have something
known bad come up when we know that
we're infected we know that there's
malware automatically replicating itself
to every single machine and we want to
shut that down
but we know what it looks like we want
to wait to roll out some kind of
signature that says if you see this file
don't allow it which is another big step
to get through on Windows we can use the
anti-malware scan interface for this
this is a central operating system API
that lets arbitrary programs talk to
whatever malware scanner is a
neighborhood so it's not tied to any
particular product and it doesn't even
necessarily tell you that there's a
product on the other end when you call
it but it's a way to say here
is some code or here is a file that I'm
about to execute do you think this is
okay or not and it will give you a
essentially a yes/no answer for this one
will we use the compile hook which I'll
show you on the next slide but here is
the helper function for verifying it
again it's a single function call MC
scan buffer and we're passing in the
code which we've got because someone's
trying to compile this code and the file
name the file name is mostly for
reporting purposes because if this
detects something it's going to set off
alarm bells and it you know has to be ah
to tell you which thing is got the alarm
and if the result says this is malware
then we say okay the file is blocked
again fairly straightforward integration
into an existing service that we're
using for everything else the hook
around this is the compile event so
we're going to check if it's if this is
the event and if it is then we're
extract the parameters the parameters
are fixed for every event so you don't
have to worry about the contents of this
changing though I will say for this
example I've abbreviated it slightly
there's a couple of edge cases to worry
about with compile and then we call the
scan function or a helper for that
function and if it says the file is
blocked we raise an exception and we
don't go any further when you run this
this gets fairly interesting so I have
to call a function to get a test string
the reason I have to do this is because
the string is encrypted in that file
the reason the string is encrypted in
that file is because if I just have
actual malware in a test file then the
malware scan is not going to let me run
the test because it's going to detect it
and say this file is blocked before I've
even gotten as far as running it because
they're all watching the filesystem
already because it's encrypted in the
filesystem it doesn't see it at first
then when I decrypt it in memory it has
no actual way of finding it until I take
that string and I eval it and when I
pass it to eval that's going to compile
the code which would trigger the compile
event which will trigger the malware
scan which is going to report that it's
malware because that's what that string
means and we're going to block
compilation
because of that we're also going to get
this little pop-up because that's what a
malware scanner does I ran this locally
if you're running this setup in a
network you'll get a distributed event
it's gonna fire everywhere your
administrator is going to know I'm
probably having my machine investigated
right now for the amount of malware
triggers that showed up when I was
testing this because they get sent to
the administrator that's the whole idea
you need to know what's going on in your
system this is a great way to find out
but the really cool thing about malware
scanners is they're designed to take
updates frequently and independently so
once this was deployed when new malware
is found that shows up as a signature
update which this does not require
redeploying the entire system in fact
they largely happen every hour or two if
you're on the fastest path but it
doesn't require shutting down your
system it's designed to be able to apply
the new signature without shutting
everything down it's not a deployment
step it's not even a configuration
change and so for example when we had
the the big ransomware spreads going on
a couple of years back patio and not
patio I want to cry all of those though
they were largely shut down because we
got the signatures out to the malware
scanners and whether you're installing
operating system updates or not you're
getting those signature updates and once
we had the signatures in they were just
blocked and they were no allowed to run
and that's largely how the spread has
stopped of these things you get them
through a malware scanner that is not
deploying updates it's not forcing you
to reboot or anything along those lines
and so now we can integrate that with
Python for handling encrypted code or
in-memory code the third scenario is log
everything everything it just log it you
need that information because the most
important thing as I've said a few times
is not preventing attack from getting in
as much as it is knowing that they're in
because once you know they're in once
you know what they're doing
you can formulate a directed response
plan as long as you're trying to defense
10 million entry points there's no way
you'll be able to cover them all off but
the engineers in the room are all going
I walk everything that's gonna be really
slow
and yes yes it is for an individual
request or task if you add lots and lots
of logging it's going to be a little bit
slower on the other hand if an attacker
gets in and steals your customer
database and publishes that are on the
internet and your company has to pay a
GD P R violation and you get shut down
because you go bankrupt your website is
going to be a whole lot slower than if
you had the logging in and you may be
optimizing for the wrong scenario the
good news is all the loading
infrastructure that you would have
access to is designed to deal with this
problem it's all higher performance than
anything you're going to roll yourself
and the Windows Event log is included in
this and we'll see why the primary
reason is deferred formatting so to
write to the Windows Event log you
define all of the events that you're
going to do it's more XML here's the
interesting part
we have a template here so any event is
going to have a certain amount of data
that has to be included and here's where
we define that so we can say up front
this takes two strings we give them
names and by saying the in type is an C
string that really just means contrast
are it's an 8 bit string and when we log
the event all that's going to happen is
that will be copied and stored somewhere
it's really efficient the formatting
message doesn't get used until much
later on when someone actually goes to
read that event that's where this string
gets loaded they do the formatting
they'll use that utf-8 marker to say
when we read this text treated is utf-8
but compared to say a print statement
where you're doing all the formatting up
front they're doing all the string
conversion up front this is going to
have much less impact on your code as
it's running and the substitutions occur
later as well so it's the deferred
formatting for these two fields that
provides a lot of the performance
improvement when we run this huge XML
file through the standard tool it gets
converted into two things the first is
actual code that you can use to raise
the event so it's a header file to see
header file that you can import and call
that will raise the event which makes it
very simple to connect into the event
log and the other half is a file that
contains all of the messages
message drink doesn't even end up in
your program and so when you go to view
the events it looks like this we have a
Python operational log operational is
the term that we use here to just say
things that we expect normal operation
you can have a separate one for security
events or errors or fatal events
whatever you whatever would make sense
for your particular context based on
what you're collecting and an event as I
said gets formatted later so you can see
the contents here has been formatted
with that string and we have the file
name included and if you're familiar
with the contents of the Python standard
library you'll recognize that that's the
actual code from that file it's been
logged it's been collected and this all
gets done in our compiled event again so
the compiler vent gets raised not just
when someone calls the exact or eval it
gets code for every single file that
gets imported from Python sauce so it's
one nice central point where every
single bit of code that gets executed
can be collected and can be reviewed for
whatever you want to do in this case if
it's not the compile event will bail out
we extract the code as before and we
call that generated function to simply
just say log this data so there's no
formatting there's no text of the
message here this is true string copies
and then we're done and minimal overhead
for logging and so with the minimal
overhead yes you should just log
everything but to add on to that the
caveat to that is remember that
everything you log you also have to read
and so I really want to emphasize you
should enable what makes sense because
if you don't have the people who are
willing to wade through all of these
events or you don't have the people who
are willing to apply anomaly detection
or machine learning to these events to
identify things that stand out then
there's very little point enabling
everything this is not simply a case Y
collection is enough its collection is
the start of the process you can build a
huge data set and as we know that's
great but you actually have to do
something with that data set to get any
use out of it knowing your opponent is
so
important because I guarantee that most
of you don't actually know who your
opponent is because we mostly think that
we're the good guys and we don't have
opponents people who are working against
us if you're running anything in the
cloud you're a target because the real
target might be someone in the same data
center as you and an attack is going to
go through your machine to get to that
and sure they don't know you they don't
hate you but they're still going to use
you and you'll be breached as part of
that or maybe the maybe your opponent is
not even an actual person it's generally
considered now that the not Pecha
malware from a few years back was a
targeted attack against a couple of
Ukrainian companies and yet within 24
hours it spread around the entire world
because people have on reward because
they weren't prepared for that kind of
entrance into their system auditing
hooks in Python 3.8 allow you to take
control security and python is no longer
a case of simply remove it because
that's all we can do it's not a case of
let's wait for the open source
developers to figure it out because
they're never going to do it like they
we myself included are never going to do
exactly what you need the choice is not
between getting rid of titan the choice
now is are your tools going to serve you
and your users and empower your
attackers or are they going to act as an
early warning system Athens 3.8 can be
your early warning system make your
attackers waive their own red flag when
they get into your system and let your
security teams know that it's time for
you to upgrade thank you
[Applause]